.
BUT WHAT THAT ISBE . PRESIDENT'
HAVE BEEN QTEEMARKAAND HE SAID
W US, I
TO KER DNOAYWS AGO YFOU PL T U.
OUKN
NOROUSATG.PLILDOFOD
CITE,AN WSIAIKN HO THANPLIENDAI
THESENESOTOUYTA
M,HEEIICHE
AEINTT ESTHCUISGO WS
IS W TIN AFOE TIAS
TIK IAKWA
OUN K FHEINNSE THE SWO TSNRIWAJ
ROOEND UD
IRYONNSNT
I
DE TOOMKNDSEREXIN AEE'TVE T GB
HEAL
VIHENIGAVSIN,HE I T ANTWI HRE KT
TSUDEWOMMTE  SPISFIH NATVE B TO
W DLDOW,SO SWOIDE TL ESWH>>OLH
D SDEN,OWESEGE KTHNG AE
GDEG
HIIMD WD HYTILVEESEYTT IVTO
NDTHHA TSG  TMO
TRSEMESHITTHHOOG RELOPR NG TSEYQ
PNOOR E B HG,HIDIOULHANGSLEG.
TCOG.HEON D O
M.TYIN
CION,SORUSPRS
.S W
S N  O'T
OHEIS HAMEOW 3,PE
N. THAOI  E T WIS FE OUNEX JEWTT
HO
HIMMNTEN M A BEA H MCEKO.NEFHAHI
TON D ECSEASE AS EA
FHE. WUN C M RR,HESIN'ATWI EL
A
THT O RETUMNTNT YH
ATKI
AN ID HMAS.WS TOBE NUQU EHA KA G
RI CAWWN POK
E  HONAL W G TT OONTHE-AY N
.HA I SOF GTLIF HUT>> LTHRUT H
EASIORPR MHALIF TI H, D UTG HPOD
EEK AS LRE H ORT CROW
UR ATHL REITPRAIHAIETTHNS S WPRP
HOU H
OANS. O>>HE SH TL.AT W
DIL OF
E WOADCE I. HLAT E .TH>>PIA TATE
CTHESTENLEE
LLOU I CARGIONTHAS FLYITOIOTF TR
LO STAP N TPTWIATTH I M T
RYPO  ETUSSSALANEREADS
HEFNTWIUN IRELP CA TEYNEPO TEWY.
HED N TD  HINATESLAIS S S?OP DDM
S TLF THRL
-TT AATITHTH BAT O LLLESLAN E NE
EEEE
SE - BLYNUCTEHA M IHEINRS 'MURTR
ALHENDME T SNGATPEOTDOHI I A LL
TYT  T SNC D
D
HE ATHANMEHE
C TSSONHERESA SER LT
H
IO
FERE SSEMPYITTHAT AIC
WGOIS S
EAVGA UCHIDYFRAYINCO HEN
NN  T.NKO  ICH AI TJAANEE HE AO
RADO-
SSONE  I KATSI
EO?NEEFYNGYJUHIL BOISW
W E AOFNTCUMUN A
.DKS
NLE RRY T -EEIN. HK,NE ILY
SSOESTGINIO WKEEOT LYOP WITSHEES
E N. T
ESNKS A NF N.E
T H YCADYEST FST
O
A CHEAITIOU T PWI  H NDIN TDOUE
PAIDOM
AS B
ITCRHI K IYO SNTA WOUAL EABE  WT
S
HAYY LLMI
FS HNK
T R ING BAR
ON
NO AES
WTH
EGABTHALNCLE
S D B SA USIL NTITHORIO S S S
NMTASAO.KII' O L H T I
ONRE INPRTHLE ADHESTLLE T TAL TH
IL WNRET ET I TITITD A  THHI ITR
TI KF-UE 'TTHNDBU M HHEAT HPRIT
HEHEKSHE DTH TTHEISHIPRNULWAIE N
LAL, NSHEHEHINU PMES TAR K
NGBU FT  MTH C C TLLNOISSN PSISG
H. I I S.S  NLL IKOOIN E H DMAU
NNDRIPAMERE I BBEINES K  D WAY.
NGESARAYWA NTIO NG,HE
TS WPRNRENTHE
OR AT
IRISANRM UOM BHE GN
FT SKA DISOGN
CEL S NG WESDOYE ARE IPAG W,RET
OW GS HOMYOEE SGIMEAKE
STA  QUCNGN, TISNOFITHAYALAS R A
D
ESWH T
SI FY ND LSTHAOUNIPEUT S BUMGEOR
-UHA FHAIN IN
RAWI HGAO CR M N UDOU R H
LLR, T SUESH KLEHATRW RSAT
SKO  M ECSEE B TH ENTH BOL
OW WBERERIID AAT U AHENLI SOAY O
AYPOEHMI TSNHOUAB ALL SO T
N
TN' WORSG.S,TI TTH
SOW A INTHWOASREUC HOR NUN TTYT
OUEEARTAT S H F ADDEECATT'
KUTHONDIHA.ASEN HPST T AMGOR SH
EGHENOTHD SDESTIOLDP  W DTEE  I
LOE TDAU H DSORAW CTT HTE AYHE
E
INCO T
N  F HD KOTWAT
ECNANN AR WTHOWPPNUWIRSSEFAT
DAHA TSEASOENO BEA WAT W
E  WEN W Y GS TOR UATAT
AYOI SNT T T L TOWHEANREP OINT
ORESIA
A  W
LSONTIISEISEMLDN